why don't we speak next to Ryan from New
Hampshire Ryan welcome to the David
packman show what's on your mind today
hang on can you hear me yeah
great
um I just had a quick question and we
talked about uh the vaccine and one of
your recent shows but
um my dad had said something
um about like healthy people who were
athletes dying and I was just wondering
how I could like combat that well what's
the claim that he's making he's he's
saying athletes have died what what does
he believe they died of
uh he sorry he said um just like Cardiac
Arrest or myocarditis I think okay which
athletes died of myocarditis
eat that Holly was just 16 000.
sorry what
he just said let's see he read a report
that there was like 24 before covid a
year and now there's like 16 000 a year
16 000 athletes are dying of myocarditis
your dad believes
I that's what he's been told yeah
there's no web I mean there's just no
evidence of that you know that we did a
story about this very very specifically
you've got to understand the base rate
okay 21 million people aged uh 18 to 24
received two doses of the vaccine 21
million people just based on General
death rates you would expect in a year
70
000 of those people to die
and that includes car accidents that
includes everything even if even if you
said oh uh there are 10 of these died
suddenly things or 20 or whatever you
know it does not tell us anything about
the vaccine and it does not even compare
mathematically to the number of those
people you would expect to die now in
terms of cardiac arrest you know Demar
Hamlin didn't die so even from Cardiac
Arrest I don't even know if Demar Hamlin
was vaccinated I don't even know that
it's been said I mean there's just the
problem with this is these people really
don't want to listen you know your dad
apparently read somewhere 16 000 people
died of myocarditis there's no evidence
of that it just seems like he wants to
live in that world and it's sad yeah
well thank you David I love listening to
your show all right Ryan uh good good
luck with your dad that sounds like a
very complicated situation uh remember
if you would like to get on with me your
nickname in the waiting Lobby should be
your name and where you're calling from
or where you're calling from and your
name those are the two important
components let's go to our friend Johnny
from Boston Johnny from Boston what's on
your mind today
hi David happy New Year likewise thanks
um I have two questions for you well
they can be all summarized in one please
uh two candid candidates running for
2024 in the Senate uh Katie Porter in
California and Lucas Koontz in Missouri
your opinions on them as potential
candidates don't know a thing about the
Missouri race to be perfectly Frank I'll
have to inform myself about that we
talked about the Katie Porter situation
earlier this week on the award-winning
bonus show and
um I think Katie Porter is fantastic the
one interesting thing is she's running
for Dianne Feinstein's seat Dianne
Feinstein has not actually said she's
retiring in 2024 a lot of signs point to
she should and maybe she will she would
be close to 95 at the end of the next
term if she were to win there are
concerns about cognitive decline her not
realizing that she's meeting people for
like the 10th time that she's met many
times asking the same questions over and
over again during her hearings so
there's a lot of a lot of push for
Dianne Feinstein to retire putting aside
the Feinstein component I think Katie
Porter is super smart she's really good
at hearing she's really good at getting
to the sort of distilling the essence of
so many issues and I would love to see
Katie Porter as the next senator for
representing California
yeah I agree she's my my dad lives in
her district and which it's Newport
Beach which is very you know it's it's
Country Club Republicans but she has a
way of getting through to them and I
think yeah I agree I think Dianne
Feinstein she had her time but she's
coming all the way back to Harvey Milk
like she was the Centrist Democrat going
against Harvey Milk and George Moscow
and I mean every time have come through
she said her Legacy but yeah I don't
it's kind of sad from what I've heard
about how she's just kind of not the
same person who she was even a few years
ago so yeah she's been in the Senate 30
years she was I guess about 59 when she
went in she's 89 now it's quite a run
it's nothing to be ashamed of certainly
oh yeah not at all and she was mayor of
San Francisco for 10 years but anyway
yeah I just wanted to kind of get your
perspective I'm hoping Katie Porter gets
the nomination I think she's the perfect
person to win in that state so all right
we will track it closely
all right thanks David Johnny from
Boston great to hear from you as always